welcome to the heavy spoilers show
i am your host paul and this video we're
breaking down the seventh episode of
lovecraft country
titled i am see say we we only do
highbrow jokes here
now i just want to get straight into the
breakdown but if you're new to the
channel then be warned that there will
be spoilers for the entire episode
so if you haven't had a chance to check
it out yet then i highly recommend that
you turn off this video
until you watched it without the way
thank you for clicking this
let's get into lovecraft country okay so
the episode title this time is pretty
straightforward
with this following hippolyta as she
attempts to define who she really is
she goes through a wealth of journeys in
this entry that are enabled by her
saying i
am and then a suffix of what she wants
to be
the title itself could be referencing a
number of works
ranging from books to movies now the
most notable examples of these are of
course
i am legend which was both a film and
book
there's also i am the power of
discovering who you really are by howard
falco
and i am which is a 2010 film this is an
anthology of four short films that
depicts the struggles of individuals
as they try to find their identity in an
unsympathetic world
all of these apply to this entry i feel
but let me know if there's anything else
that you think should make the list
by now the director of the show has
probably come out and said something
that's made me look stupid
so thanks in advance for that now we
pick up with hippolyta scrolling over
notes on the ori
which we learned she's become obsessed
with after discovering the truth about
george
we revisit the lodge with her to find it
in the runes that tick left it in
and here she finds the cover for arithia
blue a character that de-invented
and throughout this episode hippolyta
pretty much becomes her
now after crashing out on the bed and
staring at the ori
she realizes that the panels of it have
to be tilted to actually rotate how they
are on their axis and this opens up the
central sun
which holds a key and some coordinates
now coordinates actually become
extremely important in the entry
and they not only dictate a location but
also its place in time and space this is
something known as space time
which in physics takes the three
dimensions of space and fuses it with a
point in time
to create one precise number for example
if you went to the coffee shop this
morning at 8 30 am
we would not only have a location for
you but also the date the 28th of
september 2020
at 8 30 a.m if we built a time machine
we'd be able to input the exact
coordinates of the location and then the
time and date
to go back to that precise moment when
you ordered that
delicious coffee which i wish i was
having now now throughout the episode
hippolyta uses space-time coordinates to
go on a lot of adventures
and i just want to give a shout-out to
sheriff of body on reddit for marking
out the actual
points on this diagram to show where she
jumps to
now the inscription on the ori reads
every beginning is in time
and every limit of extension in space
i've tried looking this up but i can't
find anything related to it
so let me know if you have any idea
where the quote originates from
after the reveal that christina was in
fact william ruby has a lot of questions
and we join them in the off-limits
basement of the former's house
we did theorize that christina was
actually taking the blood from william
and dell's body
and here we get that confirmed with her
explaining the inner workings of the
transformation potion
it does seem that dell actually died all
the way back in episode 2
and that christina has been harvesting
her since then
to top it off we learned that christina
and william were actually in love
and like we guessed he did die at the
hands of captain lancaster
neither william or christina are in the
book but i feel like they've been woven
into the story
really nicely here and it sets up a much
more intense rivalry between her and
lancaster
than was in the source material we
learned that because christina's father
wouldn't teach her how to use magic due
to her gender
that she sought out william and seduced
him initially she just wanted to learn
magic to
impress her father but now her ambition
goes far beyond that
and we see this murder in ruby who wants
to be so much more than the expectations
that are set out for her
there's also an interesting line in
which christina says that the words
coming from william's mouth were
actually her own and that she had grown
feelings for her
which i think will set up a lot of big
twists down the line
they also mention the lost pages in the
book of names being tied to ruby's
family
which is when we jump to her sister
letty having a dream about hannah
escaping the burning lodge
we discovered that letty is in fact
pregnant and there are other teasers
throughout the episode
such as her hating the smell of golic
another common sign of being with child
being with child you really need to
widen my vocabulary now
i have seen some people theorize that
this could hint that letty is actually
related to tick
and we all know hbo loves a good incest
storyline
however i don't think that's the case
this is the first time that letty has
actually had a dream like this
and i think the new life inside of her
being tick's child has also meant that
the baby within her is feeding visions
of its ancestors
tickers started to translate the pages
and he's about halfway there
but really struggling with getting his
head around it he realizes that
because the pair had a similar dream
that hannah could be trying to send them
a message
being sent these warnings by hannah
could give them a distinct advantage
over christina
and captain lancaster and they may be
able to find the book faster
tick sets out to discover more about his
family namely his mother's side
and he journeys to montrose's who spent
the night with sammy
sammy discusses how he bumped into a
woman who said they bought
an african scarf for marshall fields
even though no black people worked there
this is a call back to ruby's storyline
who had to change into a white woman in
order to get a job at the store
it does seem that tamara did get fired
as sammy says
he hasn't seen a black girl in there and
as we know the manager paul was looking
to get rid of her
take arrives to find him and sammy in
the middle of a fight
he realizes that tree was telling the
truth we learned that tick's mother
did in fact know about montrose's
sexuality and this is likely why
she had an affair with george i think it
adds a lot of weight to george actually
being ticks further
i do believe that the character will
return through the use of time travel
in the book the character didn't die and
he was quite a big part of it
so i do think that they will be bringing
him back at some point beyond what we
see throughout this century
tick leaves after calling him the f word
and that he stays behind to learn about
his family
she discovers that tick's mother had a
cousin that lived in tulsa
and that she also survived the riots
tick heads out to saint louis to
discover what's going on
but he's clearly shaken up by his
father's revelation
now he did theorize that montrose's
father beat him so badly
because he knew his son was gay and that
he married a woman in order to avoid
persecution
by both his dad and society he in turn
be atticus when he was younger
because that's how he was raised and
also he had trouble dealing with the
fact that he was living a lie
we see this almost generational violence
being passed on from father to son
and get the idea of history repeating
itself it's more harrowing because we
now know that tick is going to become a
father
and he could end up going down the same
path as both his dad and grandfather
tick has a darker side to him which
we've now seen first hand
and it'll be interesting to see how
things play out with him and his child
they head to hippolyta to ask if they
can borrow the car woody
in order to drive there but h is raging
because she knows they lied about george
h refuses to hand it over and let he
stays behind to talk to ruby
who's babysitting d this is the first
time they've spoken since their big
fight over the money
and ruby forgives her but doesn't
mention the order of the ancient dawn
so actually think that she might still
be working for christina
in the book ruby was pretty much
addicted to the elixir
and she ended up doing way more jobs
than just planting the medallion
though i think she's probably broken the
potions hold on her
perhaps she hasn't broken christina's
and still is in her pocket
we like to see letty playing cards with
the kids really badly
and one of the boys asks when bobo is
coming back as he knew how to play
bobo was actually the nickname of emmett
till who popped up in an earlier episode
and in real life till was sadly murdered
by a white mob
and thus we as an audience know he's not
going to be coming back
on the road h heads to the coordinates
on the ori and we can hear her listening
to josephine baker
singing in french baker pops up later in
the episode
and the pair meet in paris so this is a
nice bit of foreshadowing
bessie stringfield also passes her on a
motorbike
and bessie was actually a real-life
figure who was the first black woman to
ride across the us
she was also a dispatch rider for the us
army in the second world war
and i love how the show has these
legendary figures popping up from
time to time h arrives at the
observatory in mayfield
and those that have read the book will
instantly recognize this location
as hiram epstein's tick ends up getting
the bus to st
louis where he meets his mother's cousin
to talk about the book of names
but unfortunately she says it was
burning the riots though we don't know
if this is true or not
now we realize that tick and his cousin
have the same birthmark on their skin
and this could indicate that they are
indeed from the same bloodline as titus
braithwight
i believe that lancaster wishes to
sacrifice people connected to the elder
in order to gain his power and knowledge
and this is what montrose and jia have
been trying to warn him about
letty has discovered the uri and she
rings tick to tell him the coordinates
ruby is also spying on her which further
adds to our theory
now hippolyta finds a lock similar to
the one on the ori
and after placing in the key she works
out the math required to start it up
i love how she juts this down on the
travel guide as
she of course travels across the
universe and again
nice bit of foreshadowing which i
appreciate now during this
lancaster's forces arrive and we learn
that they've been at the location
keeping tabs on it lancaster knows of
this because he and hyrum work together
and tick arrives as they start to
question her she falls against the
machine which powers it up
and i'll i love in tv shows and movies
when someone bangs against the machine
and it instantly starts working just hit
it as hard as you can
now a bottle opens which sucks h in and
she's hurtled across time and space
you're not in kansas anymore dorothy
that was terrible that was such a bad
impression
she lands on a planet which is where she
comes face to face with some robotic
looking extraterrestrials
she's taken to a strange looking room
and ends up donning some overalls
that look like ripley's an alien i don't
know if that's just me reaching
but she's greeted by a giant alien with
an afro
who's named seraphina aka beyonce say
in the credits this is obviously a
reference to beyonce
and the french words say which further
ties back to paris
now an interesting bit about this scene
is that the coordinates change
very slightly even though she's in the
same location
this is to demonstrate time itself
changing and it is a confirmation of the
space-time coordinates
she takes apart the table and using a
piece of it
prize open the circuitry on the door
which unlocks it
just as she's about to escape seraphina
returns and blasts her back
this time commanding that she names
herself she says she wants to be dancing
on stage in paris with josephine baker
and is instantly transported to this
location
josephine baker was an american-born
french entertainer that was also
a civil rights activist and french
resistance member
there's also an appearance by frida
kahlo who was a famous artist
as for h she gets her very own moulin
rouge
and judging by the change in the
coordinates h spends
months and months at this location she
might have even bumped into a younger
sammy
but again probably reaching there again
now h says something very interesting to
josephine
that reflects what christina said
earlier in the episode
she states all those years i thought i
had everything i ever wanted
only to come here and discover that all
i ever was
was the exact kind of black woman white
folks wanted me to be
i feel like they just found a smart way
to lynch me without me noticing a noose
i just want to kill white folks and it's
not just them
i hate me for letting them make me feel
so small
it's laced with a lot of subtext that
shows she pretty much had to turn
herself into a shallow commodity
in order to be someone realizing that
she has to go beyond what she's
discovered
she says i am hippolyta which transfers
her to an alternate dimension
in which she trains with an african
amazonian tribe
in classical greek mythology hippolyta
was actually the queen of the amazons
which i think this is riffing on this
confirms the many worlds theory which
states that
alternate realities exist in which all
events and outcomes are possible
the tribe are training to battle a band
of white confederate soldiers
and h again spends countless days
working towards the showdown
i also kind of got a princess of mars
vibes here
which is a book that has appeared in the
series the battle
is awesome and h co completely decimate
the soldiers
using what she said to josephine she
inspires the group even more
and soldiers run towards them but h
holds down the
the the l r buttons in final fantasy
and escapes proclaiming that she's
george's wife
now this is clearly another alternate
dimension in which george didn't die
george is over the moon that she had
endless possibilities
but still chose to be his wife out of
all of them though it's a happy moment
she realizes that george in many ways
held her back
and states that he dulled her shine
george of course didn't want her to have
any part in the guidebook creation
and thus this stifled her progress and
in fact
led to his death she states that she
wished to name something out of this
world
and this is a call back to the book in
which the character named pluto
but was beaten by a white girl who was
able to send communication to the
registry office
before her due to using a telegram it's
also hinted at earlier in the season
when a similar situation happened with a
comet and h was not given credit due to
the competition runners not wishing to
have a black girl's face on their
publishing
she finally gets us off her chest and
george said he did this in order to keep
her safe
but as we've seen she's more than
capable of handling herself
h proclaims itself as hippolyte a
discoverer and together the two land on
something
that looks like it belongs in no man's
sky i also love how that the spaceship
is actually similar and looks to the car
woody
and we hear the words of sunraw in the
background they travel throughout the
universe creating their own travel guide
of this alien solar system
and what is truly a beautiful scene she
reunites with seraphina
who offers her a place in her society
but hippolyta instead chooses to return
home in order to be dee's mother
though she has expanded beyond all
things this time it's her choice to
shrink down
rather than someone else's tig is thrown
out of the portal
and it seems like he too has gone on his
own journey
and he now carries the actual book
lovecraft country
it's a fourth wall breaking moment and i
wonder if he's now traveled to our
universe in order to get the piece of
fiction
which will of course contain the book of
names as for next week
i'm not sure i can even spoil this as it
looks pretty alien from the book with
the show clearly diverting from the
source material
it seems like captain lancaster has
captured d and he's questioning her
about magic
elsewhere we also see ruby drink a
potion perhaps hinting that she will be
transforming back into dell
it looks like tick is actually creating
an uprising against the police
and lancaster seems to be getting much
more of a focus
so it does seem like he will be going
head-to-head with the group now
christina seems to be working with take
two which
that's a bit more in line with the book
but yeah still
a lot of things up in the air now
obviously i'd love to your thoughts on
the episode
so make sure you comment below and let
me know don't forget we're also giving
away a free copy of the christopher
nolan collection and all you have to do
to begin with the chance of winning is
like the video
subscribe to the channel and drop a
comment below the winner is going to be
chosen at random on the 30th of
september
so make sure you get involved if you
want to support the channel and get to
see content early
then please consider clicking the join
button below you can also come chapters
on our discord server linked in the
description
or heavy spoilers on twitter thanks for
making it until the end of the video
you've been the best i've been paul and
i'll see you next time
take care peace
[Music]
[Music]